welcome to CBS this morning we're going
to begin with this this first hour the
house impeachment inquiry may be
entering a new phase after a day of
testimony that Democrats call detailed
damning and disturbing the top US
diplomats in Ukraine that's Bill Taylor
laid out how President Trump held up
military aid for Ukraine as he pushed
its leaders to investigate Democrats and
a company linked to former Vice
President Joe Biden's son the White
House called the inquiry a coordinated
smear campaign and said there was no
quid pro quo on Ukraine Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill Nancy what else did we
learn from Taylor's testimony well we
learned that there were phone calls and
meetings and cables where this strategy
was discussed and where the Ukrainians
were pressured to cooperate told to say
what the president wanted to hear
ambassador Taylor says he found the
situation alarming and made it clear
that what he witnessed he believed was a
quid pro quo mr. Taylor what led you to
be concerned about a quid pro quo in
nearly 10 hours of testimony ambassador
bill Taylor described a secret campaign
to pressure Ukraine using millions in
military aid as leverage is the most
disturbing day in Congress so far very
troubling he is probably one of the most
credible witnesses I've ever seen Taylor
is a veteran civil servant who was asked
to return to his post in Ukraine this
summer according to his 15 page opening
statement he encountered a highly
irregular US policy making effort
they're led by mr. Trump's personal
attorney Rudy Giuliani this is not just
rogue Rudy Giuliani self-dealing in
Ukraine he's an agent of the president
Taylor said that by mid-july it was
becoming clear that a meeting the
Ukrainian president sought with mr.
Trump was conditioned on the
investigation of BER yzma the energy
company that employed the son of
presidential candidate Joe Biden Taylor
said he was told that everything
including millions of dollars in u.s.
security assistance depended on zalenski
publicly announcing an investigation
related to the
and the 2016 election the money held up
had absolutely nothing to do with by
this tailors testimony directly
contradicted the white house line there
was no quid pro quo at all mr. Trump
isn't making it easy for allies to
defend him the president has said that
you told him that his phone call with
the Ukrainian president was perfect and
innocent we've not had any conversations
on a subject so he was lying about that
you hope that count
despite that dispute McConnell and other
Republicans insist that the president is
being denied due process and after that
ten-hour closed-door deposition one
republican mark meadows came out and
said he still does not see the evidence
of a quid pro quo
Anthony Nancy in a tweet the president
used the word lynching to describe the
Democrats inquiry what was the reaction
on the hill to that well harsh
condemnation from Democrats who said
that the president's use of that word
minimizes the history of hate crimes
against black Americans and many
Republican leaders also said that it was
not the language that they would have
chosen but other Republicans pointed out
that it's not the first time that this
term has been used in a political
context they pointed to 1998 when
then-senator Joe Biden used the term
before Bill Clinton's impeachment
proceedings began after he was reminded
of that on twitter joe biden said quote
that wasn't the right word to use and
i'm sorry about that Trump on the other
hand he added chose his words
deliberately today in his use of the
word lynching and continues to stoke
racial divides in this country
Anthony Nancy Cordes Thank You Nancy